e
all right we'll get going here it's a
little after 10:15 we have Senate Bill
347 relative to infrastructure
Appropriations for reimbursement to the
city of lonia and before I do start we
have a sub with us today representative
Lang will be with this for Lane I'm
sorry Lane that's starting out well here
um welcome you'll find our group very uh
good to work with and uh we got a good
team here so welcome and she'll be
filling in for representative huitt who
is U
out all right is there anyone here that
347 members of the division any
comments recommendations I will
point out and thanks to the work that
Melissa has done as you probably already
know
um the sale has on the lonia property
has fallen through and we did hear this
bill back
on the 17th of April it came out of the
Senate on a Voice vote there were two
people that testified in favor of the
bill at our public hearing but that's
have representative
Griffin yeah I I really don't understand
the bill if there's going to be a
development of the uh the
area that's that's the bill we're
talking about
right why isn't the developer paying the
$3 million why is the state
paying it's a good question U and again
I don't see anybody here to can answer
that question representative grassy any
comment it's being charged against the
sale proceeds from the sale of the
property so I'm assuming is when the
property does sell either we will get
our money back or we'll pay those bills
out of that money and this also goes
until um the Appropriations made for the
bium ending June
2025 so you know what we're looking at
here is we've got plenty of time to sell
the property and I suppose if the
property doesn't sell in the meantime we
would end up pay pay that material but
then we would get it back when the
property
sold and if I'm not correct on that
please let me know no based on the
fiscal note I believe you're correct it
shows Melissa this was updated on the
20th of December is anything new as far
as a fiscal note uh Noe that is correct
I did want to point out one thing that I
didn't actually include in the email but
that did occur in Senate finance and um
the sponsor Senator Lang did speak to
and that this $3 million essentially was
to the project for the sale of this
property because it was supposed to be
turned into affordable housing units um
so I'm not sure where this bill stands
if that sale fell through would you
still need the 3 million for
infrastructure because you don't know
what the sale would be next whoever
would buy it next are they still
planning on doing affordable housing or
would it be something different so I did
just want to point that out that
occurred in Senate Finance since no
one's here to
testify thanks Melissa we pres Griffin
thank you Mr chair um I'd like to
comment on representative grassley's
comment and say that the $3 million
comes out of the state we sell the we
sell the property for 20 million and we
get 17 we're out 3 million that we don't
need to be
out my my opinion is that property's
going to be developed if it's a
premature development and the
infrastructure should coming to the
property needs to be upgraded that
should fall on the developer not the
state represent Maguire uh thank you Mr
chairman so the other disturbing thing
we heard about this whole issue is we
spent 13 million spent of this money
already to buy a granite place right so
I don't know where we're getting that
money and then and and I don't know if
should we maybe so to me this is sort of
an obvious itl because we're not ready I
mean this this the Project's gone the
sale is gone and stuff but I is there
any possibility that we should hold this
bill to do something with to to solve
the granite Place problem do Melissa do
you know what's going on with that
if I don't know I do know in hb2 that
obviously the 13 million for granite at
Place one was contingent on the sale of
this currently they are leasing it so I
don't know if just the lease would
continue until they have the funds to
purchase it but I don't have an update
on
that any further comment representative
Griffin I certainly agree with
your uh description because it's 3
million that the state wouldn't in fact
be out of if we reimburse the city of
lonia repres M all right I'll move
itl seconded by representative
and so Melissa maybe you could ask um
Department of administrative Services
place okay um so SB 347 the motion U is
itl representative M
yes
uh
know let's see what's today okay the
Maguire motion of itl passes 7 to
zero we do have five minutes yeah I'm
can
e
all right we'll get started with Senate
Bill 393 relative to making
appropriation to the Department of
Environmental Services to fund Regional
drinking water
infrastructure
uh Senate President Morris would you
like to speak on this bill I would be
happy to uh hear from
you no that's all right we don't mind
Mr Mr chairman um thank you um I just
want to eliminate some confusion that
happened in the full finance committee
in the house um I believe representative
Sweeney will be presenting an amendment
that actually speaks to what should have
come to the house finance committee but
um I just don't want anyone to think
that we're only working on one project
in the uh we work throughout the state
on water projects but in this Southern
Tier
um London der's done approved the towns
um worked out whatever funds they had to
do um that's the top one that I
presented to you again we want to
basically as a state um provide the
water line and then have the communities
pick it up and Branch out um into the
hookups and the other one that we've
been working on is Hudson um the state
funded part of this uh last year I
believe um but it's a $34 million
project the state put in 9.7 million in
that project um the 25 million's coming
locally and we explain all that at the
bottom of all of this the third project
is is phase two of a regional project um
the Senate when the original project was
presented which quite honestly hit the
house finance committee a $25 million
doll project at the Senate asked us to
take a look at phasing it in um we
worked with the department and if you
want pump details or waterline details
everybody behind me can answer all of
that but 2A is basically the engineering
so that they can go find the money for
next spring for
construction and the um 2A I believe
representative Sweeney has an amendment
for today that he can speak to and work
with you um we we are doing all kinds of
things along the way but let me explain
um something that I think is very
important from the state's point of view
as to how these things are financed I
mean we're very good at going after the
federal money we're very good at going
to the committee that we created in 20
2016 and getting money um the other part
of this is when we built this Regional
water line um there was a lot of give
from the local communities you can
imagine in Manchester Derry Salem their
Investments far exceed anything the
state's talking about anything the
millions of dollars they have into their
systems when we connected to them was
basically
a lot of lawyers and a lot of Selectmen
and counselors coming to meetings and
making an agreement which is all legally
documented and the commissioner is here
if you want to talk about that but it
involved a lot of PE people playing
nice and as we move along with this um
we know there's an issue we have to deal
with financing on to build the big
project we just don't want to get into
next year and not have it engineered so
we're here today to talk about a and I
think we can get to a resolution here
because we are working on a couple of
other things um it will it require a few
bucks in general funds that's up to this
committee um we've explored a few other
things to figure out how to pay for the
big project we're not ready to go there
right now um we certainly worked with VA
um to do some of those things um it's
just not quite ready to present so um 2B
and
2C down the road let me explain the
benefits though of a project like this
because we're all trying to sell housing
projects throughout the state and not
have the government paying for them all
if you look at 2C 2 C is the connection
to Chester New Hampshire which will
create density
and they can expand that project that
they're doing and over 55 in that
Community which I don't think we've ever
talked about Chester New Hampshire in
any of our committees for housing but
there's a project that's there and if we
can bring the water instead of having to
drill Wells um to that project which is
just outside of Derry um it will change
how things are done then I believe we're
going to connect to Sandown and maybe
go even further east but it's us
bringing the source and the developers
hooking up to it and that's what we're
trying to do with all of this I'll take
any questions you have on it but I just
wanted to show some insight on how much
is going on in the department um to make
all these projects work um they're
attending meetings nightly in our
communities to make sure we keep going
with these
projects represent mire has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um am I right that
the New Hampshire drinking water and
groundwater trust fund the way it works
is that it makes loans to local projects
and then gets paid back by those
projects they do both so there was about
280 million when we started in 16 I
think there's 9089 million 90 million
available right now in there um part of
it's in loans part of it it's in Grants
um the state's position when we built
that
committee we had $280 million with $800
million worth of problems so we were
basically going to be a third of it
whatever we were talking when we were
talking to people so as representative
Sweeney which I tried to teach him what
our thoughts were there's 6 and a half
million here you have to figure out how
to pay for 2 million 2 million and two
million and the communities while you're
doing this are applying for Grants and
doing what they have to do so um I think
what on this upfront project we are
working on a grant that's probably going
to happen that so the communities can
bring their third but all the
communities are tied together on that
application um on this Regional one so
it's it's a big deal thank you follow
followup thank you so you mentioned
Chester but looking at the three Maps
here 2 2A and two I'm sorry 2 A2 B to C
I don't see any lines getting into
Chester at
all yeah if you look at um East Dairy
2C can you see that one yes solid blue
line where the second um square is there
you'll see on one of these documents the
the developer is willing to put up the
money to bring the line to his project
so if we can get it to there um the
developer will hook up to the project I
see thank
you further questions of yes I just had
a really basic question when when you
say we who is we or are are you
representing a group or the commission I
got dragged into the state side of it
the um about a year ago when I I had
left the state house if you hadn't
noticed um You probably noticed in your
budget because um I'm not I'm not sure
how you got to 18 or 19% but um in any
case the uh um the commissioner asked me
to help and um get back into putting
these projects together um so it was
extremely important when you appropriate
the 9 million for Hudson to work with
them and get that going because that has
ties to Windom the backup supply for L
andary um and to get into pelum which
had mtbe contamination which is kind of
phasing out um but then you have the
London one which is probably the most
contaminated um when it comes to pfoas
they they have about half the units in
the state are in londondary so we were
trying to get a source into londondary
hey it was a big deal we have testified
locally um and we just keep pushing it
along I mean in 2016 I was surprised as
you are the governor was speaking in the
house and at the rostom and told me I
was in charge of this so um I've been
working on it since
2016 but it's everywhere in the state so
if you need other information on what's
going on in all parts of the state
Peterboro Jaffrey the chair knows we did
a major project to mpor over there um it
was a project that brought 500 jobs to a
company so um and it's the way we trying
to think a little unique right the
community came in here we financed about
a third we financed about 3 million I
believe in that project the $10 million
bond that was taken locally the company
agreed to
pay I mean those are kind of things the
state should be looking at and finding
ways to get these projects done so
that's what we're doing in all these
cases further questions to The Honorable
Chuck Morris yes representative Sweeney
Wonder can we have my Amendment passed
around while we have the senator here
absolutely 1793
H they know I was going to be
responsible for this no I I'll I'll I'll
push it Forward I just wanted to keep
you as the resource Senator so as
Senator mentioned this bill came to us
with the $25 million general fund uh
appropriation which which gave me a
little uh setback looking at all the
other spending we've been doing uh so
this reduces that down to a $2 million
general fund appropriation and then
authorizes a combination of federal
funds and the trust fund to 4.5 million
uh just to really get the engineering
laid out for the project so that in the
next capital budget we can really start
tackling the next construction of the of
the phases that were being disc
there is word uh that the town of Salem
secured a $2 million Federal grant that
can be utilized as well so it's really I
think when it comes down to it it'll be
probably 2.5 around that ballpark from
the trust fund uh but just to get the
engineering started brings it down to
that $2 million general fund which I
think this committee would probably have
a much higher appetite for than the 25
million you taught him well he's fairly
uh conservative fiscally so
let's back it up a bit No One Secured
anything yet on the federal side um we
there is an
application um that that's been made
it's positive but you know it you never
know until these things are done did
this project um it will move along and
it'll get taken care of this there's
also another piece in here though that
the committee should be aware of and we
left it in here um the the water level
in Lake Massabesic if we can raise it a
foot a foot I think is what we're
shooting for we financed as a state we
spent a little bit of money um under
$500,000 to do a study in Manchester to
raise that Lake that'll basically put
another chunk of water into the system
um which will allow Manchester to pump
um even more to the Southern Tier um
there's a huge benefit to that um that
is being chased in federal funds um so
we don't describe it in here we just
mentioned it um but that's part of
getting into next year and being able to
build out the
project now where does that study stand
on Massabesic the raising of the water
level I why don't you wait when they
come up they can answer that question
all right it it actually this spring
with all this rain shouldn't be a
problem it's at that
height so yeah I I think the you know
there's other issues in that that have
to be addressed so I think you can ask
Amendment I'll seeing
done anything else uh oh it's been an
honor to come before this committee and
um I look forward to a positive uh
outcome thank you well let me just say
say this you are missed here by a number
of us I could have saved enough money in
your budget to pay for this project I
knew that was
coming thank you very much yeah nice to
see
you the Department of Environmental
this good morning members you know I
always get confused a red light to me
should mean it you can't talk yet but
any
sorry uh Bob Scott Department of
Environmental Services so that so that
the department hasn't taken a position
on the funding for this project but we
absolutely support the project and we're
very involved in the project and if I
could Echo a couple thoughts that the
the senator
made to date all the work we've done in
the Southern New Hampshire tier I I'll
equate it to synchronized swimming if
you will so you know it takes the
cooperation and the resources of the
local local communities uh the work that
has been done that's gone through them
they effectively act as a general
contractor for it uh and all their and
and and devote all those resources so
there significant uh in kind match even
when they do get grant money uh and then
as the senator mentioned too the uh what
we're doing is the whole model is
leveraging their existing uh
infrastructure that they have
and their willingness to to utilize that
to pass water through to other other
needed areas of the state um so uh
perhaps I know the chair asked about the
um the lake Massabesic study uh I have
with me Mike anger who's a project
engineer for everything on this paper uh
he perhaps he can give you an update if
if the chair would like on when when
finished good morning um yes so the it's
a feasibility study that Manchester
Waterworks has an engineer under
contract and paid with Grant funds from
Dees and um it's underway now and the
final deliverables do in the fall um and
that's the goal is to identify any red
flags um and then develop a cost
estimate for the final design and
construction when's the date oh
anger have there been any uh problems at
least that have surfaced yet as far as
raising the level by a foot or no I
there's the things that you would expect
we're looking at um some of the culverts
uh Crossing roads um looking at
maintaining the flows
Downstream and you know right now it's
just conversations with the different
permitting authorities to make sure that
the process is outlined but nothing
surprising and I think the concept where
the money would be likely to be needed
is to to uh again raising the level
means some Dam dam improvements need to
be made to that empowerment so there's
some work to be done on the dams the the
good news is Manchester Waterworks
controls not 100% but most most of the
easements around the around the uh the
Water body itself also so that that's
the good news I would argue you know to
the extent this is $3
million that we end up putting into this
hopefully from federal funds um that
that that will equate to 1 billion cubic
foot of extra water to go into the
southern be available for the Southern
New Hampshire region so that also
provides uh significant backup we've
we've had things like past contamination
and other things part of that area is
getting uh pen Waterworks water uh which
is fine too but the the idea of
redundancy and and we've done a also for
the the region we've we had commissioned
a water need study uh going out in the
future and there's there's a lot of lot
of additional water need that we see
coming and that was before epa's recent
uh announcement of this four parts per
trillion uh p drinking water standard
which is going to increase the need even
more beyond that so so so I say all that
to to say the lake Massabesic thing is
probably in my experience since I've
been commissioner probably the best bank
for the buck we're going to see for
additional
water F the questions for the
commissioner representative evil thank
you well so I was looking at the
amendment and I imagine this is in it's
also in the original bill it says um 2
million gallons per day to multiple
towns impacted by past contamination
so how does that interrelate with the
stco Bain settlement uh possible EPA
infrastructure funding I mean are those
all and then of course we have a the
lawsuit
so yes man a lot of moving parts to that
as as you allude to so uh so the the
extra 2 million uh gallons per day when
we originally uh worked with the
communities on the what call phase one
to get the water through all the way to
to plastow uh it was
designed to in the long run be able to
to support over 3 3.1 million gallons
per day so the pipes were put in at that
level so we didn't have to go and dig
them up and and all that type of stuff
in a few years uh so they're they're
currently able to with with the the
bottlenecks they have right now pumping
and treatment they were able to serve
that 1.1 million ion gallons this would
eventually as as as the senator
mentioned part 2 A 2 B 2C would would uh
ultimately get to fruition the full 3.1
as envisioned uh having said that again
we've had other things happen since then
like the past thing as you mentioned so
that's why the the lake Massabesic uh
portion has now been added to give
additional Supply uh we do have not on
this paper but we're working with uh as
a senator mentioned we're working with
um lenary that will also uh use both
Manchester Waterworks and penu uh water
also so it is all interrelated and we
have as the senator mentioned we have
certain number of sources and we're
trying to make sure that we can meet all
the capacity as that as that is built
out sure so my thought there might be
other sources of funding in addition to
this as well that could help especially
from from the P side potentially yes so
that's one of the reasons why on the
chart you see Federal funding that's a
potential for f Federal funding uh also
once the water mains are put in you also
have to get the water to the the Final
End uh that's definitely an area where
used so no further questions uh the
division okay with this representative
Sweeny's Amendment just show a hands
please all
much so now if um the division is happy
we can vote on um Senate Bill 393 as
amended with this Sweeney
Amendment make that
motion okay the motion's been made by
representative Sweeney seconded by
representative EO
get my world in order here thanks Joe
yes representa Griffin yes
yes
Lane yes okay representative grassy yes
and the chair yes yes so um
two three four five six seven8 8 to zero
unanimous okay the motion passes 8 to
zero okay we'll move right along to uh
Senate Bill 453 making an appropriation
to the Statewide voter registration
system we have someone here that wishes
to
represent McGuire thank you Mr chairman
so I couldn't think of an amendment for
this bill um I think it's a worthwhile
thing to do um the only possibility is I
don't feel like it's a super high
priority so if we actually knew how much
money we have to spend you know and and
it's and we're short 450,000 I would say
maybe delay it right but other than that
I you know I guess I'm going to move um
octopath okay the motion's been made on
seconding seeing no further discussion
when the clerk is ready please call the
rooll on a to pass on
453 hang on hang on
hang I mean perhaps because
representative Lane is is a member of
the election law committee she would
like to comment certainly comment
represent
Lan please support this it's been a high
priority of the election committee for
you okay so um if people could tell me
who said seconded the motion that would
was made by represent Maguire seconded
by
Griff okay all right representative
Maguire yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrell yes clerk votes
yes representative Lane yes
representative grassy yes the chair yes
okay we have a few more minutes until we
so
e
but I I it's not really in my mind
constitutional to to vote a benefit for
a specific group family person Etc right
there's part one article 10 um so but
but I think that I mean this particular
case is one that uh should be Ben you
know should have such a benefit and um
so I so what this amendment does is it
does provide the benefit for the hos
family but it
also uh going forward provides a similar
benefit to others in a similar situation
right so so there's two there's two
parts to this the the first one is to
add um security officers so this line 24
so there's a big list of those people
that that qualify for this particular
benefit and and so line 64 adds security
officers to the list the reason that um
Chief hos was not included was he was on
he was he had been a long time law
enforcement officer but at the time he
was a security officer um and I and he
was only part-time I believe right so um
so this adds security officers to the
list and then this but the second part
is lines 15 through 18 so two years ago
the benefit in
question added suicide to the ca
possible causes of death that includ
include this and the argument at the
time was that law enforcement officers
who commit
suicide T often are victims of PTSD you
know it's the stress of the job that's
driving them to suicide and so um so
that's why the legislature and the
governor added suicide as a cause but
um but it seems to me that if someone is
in a part-time job then the then that
justification isn't really there right
so so if you're only part-time law
enforcement security
Etc then then the justification for
suicide you know for example um
uh you know hos was in a a part-time
sort of position that's not really there
so this adds a little language that says
only if you're full-time does the
suicide um aspect of this count so so it
seems to me both of these parts are
related to hos they make H's situ
situation get the benefit in a in a more
General way and the house family does
benefit thank you questions for
representative Maguire represent graphy
no nothing
represent
Lane I know I'm a sub but I guess my
question is um this seems to be a type
of a policy decision rather than a
financial decision and is this something
that was discussed in the policy
committee yes unfortunately as
representative grassy said welcome to
finance we often get
into policy which is tied into fin
Financial aspects
so I can see a point where you might
suggest it should go to Edna for
instance which deal deals with these
types of issues but go ahead I I guess
my followup is was
this addition discussed Below in the
policy uh represent McGuire could answer
that but I'm guessing
no unfortunately this this is a Senate
bill it came to us as first committee
right right so you know I mean the the
speaker could have sent it to Edna as
first committee and us as second
committee but in this case we're kind of
right further questions representative
evil it's not a question it's a comment
um I actually
like what representative Maguire has
done um because uh I can think of
several situations where the state has
been asked to provide some sort of
support for the family or some sort of
death benefit in an unfortunate um
situation and this way if we have this
as a as a matter of Statute then we can
just go back to the statute and these
families and there and whoever is
representing them um don't don't have to
go through the painful process of H
through any further comments represent
Kells yes thank you Mr chair yeah uh I
also like the bill like the way with the
amendment um the question is it's still
okay represent Maguire yeah so the the
100,000 is the standard amount for a
death benefit of a law enforcement
officer in who gets killed on the job
basically
seeing no further questions or someone
motion representative Griffin followed
by representative Sweeney making a
second Is there further
discussion seeing we'll just have a show
of hands I guess any all in
favor the amendment yeah the
amendment uh she unanimous and then when
the clerk is
ready we'll have a motion that was
offered by representative Griffin
seconded by representative
Sweeney uh to amend Senate Bill 604 by
adding the Maguire Amendment
yes
yeses
yes representative Lane yes
representative grassy yes and the
chairman
unanimous all right we only have five
minutes
welome
e
okay we'll open up U our work session on
Senate Bill
553 requiring that funds held by public
deposit investment pool be invested in
New
Hampshire do someone here like to speak
to the bill I know from Senator
rosenwall there's an amendment that
someone's going to
present
thanks Senator
rosenwall you're welcome to come forward
if you'd like I believe you have an
amendment
um it's suggested language for the
record Cindy rosenal from Senate
District
13 this amendment steps back from the
bill that I introduced to you a couple
weeks
ago um it feels like a lifetime ago but
I think it was only about two or three
weeks ago um it steps back from the
requirement that 100% of the PDP
funds um be invested in financial
institutions with a presence in New
Hampshire and it um takes the lead from
RSA
48 colon 16 which has to do with how
Municipal funds
can be invested have to be secured so
that is what you now see as
section one and that's the only
language that is different I would also
point out that down at the bottom of
this section one
2A there is a
target requirement not a floor but a
goal
of
saying at least
30% of the
funds in the pool should
be uh
in in
um banks with a footprint here it's a
goal I know that the treasurer has
some
comments on this language I think it's
you know we listen to the comments of
the towns that came in to testify I
think this language adheres to the pdip
statute which puts Safety
compromise
chair good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record State
mipel so um uh Senator Ren W was very
kind to share that Amendment with me and
um uh was able to review the amendment
and um I think um it was it's it's it's
clear that um um there is this
understanding that um you know based on
the feedback from the from the um public
hearing and and that's why this this
amendment uh was uh developed um my my
comment and I was just had of just a
minute to to right I didn't have the
opportunity to speak with Senator Rosen
before but my my comment um to to to
Senator Rosen wall is um um I still have
a little bit of concern um uh even
though this amend then is including more
Investments um that the pool can invest
in I still am a little concerned that we
have some limitations in the number of
Investments um that we that the pool
will be allowed to invest in um when we
start trying to list the type of
Investments you could the risk is that
you could live out some potential
options um for you know for the pool to
invest just like right now we do have a
wide um range of options that the pool
uh can utilize and um my concern about
limit ends and putting investments in in
the law is that for some reason
something um if the market conditions
change or um I was just using the
example of um when the debt limit the US
government was having some trouble
reaching to that deal um we were a
little concerned that the US government
was going to um um not meet um its
obligations so we reduce our position on
US government for some time and so again
in is and that's one of the safest that
is the safest investment as far as we we
know and um and again so I guess my
point is adding limitations to the law
could all could create unintended
consequences um one of the things that I
I I was hearing and I think the the
intent of this is try to uh protect the
pool which I completely understand um
and again the concern is for example the
the state this the state of New
Hampshire doesn't have a limitation we
have the ability to um invest in a lot
of type of uh Investments according to
RSA 68 uh but the way we address that
even though we have that very wide range
of options to invest this we address
those limits and those parameters in our
investment policies so that's um that
was sort of that's my intention um and
that was the conversation I wanted to
have with the senator and the bankers
Association because I think we could
probably try to address some of um the
desire to have more investments in New
Hampshire but we could probably try to
do it in the investment policy rather
than um impacting the law um and then
create unintended consequences that way
so that's what I wanted to again share
with the senator and the group but also
um for this committee to to consider uh
again this will impact not only this
amendment but the current amendment that
you're or the current uh proposal that
you're reviewing today and if I could um
if you look at RSA 48 col 16 that
limits the amount the places that
City treasurers called called City
treasurers I think probably applies to
towns too limits the the places that
they can make their Investments to
government um US
government uh
instruments and federally insured
banks with language about the amount how
the funds are secured so so there's law
about this for the cities that this
language is based on one thing I think
you could do to address the treasurer's
concerns is
in um the sentence that says beginning
June 22nd
20125 you could say any private
investment advisor approved by the state
treasur and advisory committee shall
strive to ensure and that is is
consistent with the language in Roman 2A
so it would be a Target but it would be
the legislature saying our intent is
that these funds be invested in Secure
instruments and I don't know how you
react to
that yes on the Fly Right
thank you Senator I think I think
including the intent and the law I think
that would be appropriate that we could
take that message back to the committee
reviewing and the investment policy
could be designed uh again understand
that there is this desire to have more
more Investments and you know Banks
operating in New Hampshire we can
certainly address that uh we can review
what other states are doing and we can
try to mimic some some of that
understanding that perhaps because of
the number of banks operating in New
Hampshire uh perhaps that you know we're
not going to be the same as New York uh
but if we could try to we could try to
reach a Target that again tries to meet
this desire to keep more funds in the
state but providing us that again the
flexibility to invest in other
Securities that also are um important to
maintain the stability of the funds and
also um um you know we use uh is that
have the highest credit that will allow
us to improve the yield and the pool and
that's what we all um you know we all
have this fidare responsibility to um uh
to to to obtain you know maintain those
funds preserve the funds and and obtain
the highest yield that we can possibly
uh can reach so those are my comments so
just for the division as far as the
history of this bill this came directly
to us from the Senate we had a public
hearing on the 17th of
April um the vote out of the Senate
which was back on February 24th or 21st
rather was 24 to Z representative
Griffin you had a question thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
my question is to the state treasurer I
have a background of having been a
selectman five terms I was a town
Treasurer I the investment pool as it
exists is a great great
institution the goal of the pool is to
maximize Returns on extra money and uh
within the margin of
safety and uh I'm my question I guess is
this bill in your mind fixing something
broken the pool is is a very successful
pool is not fixing a broken pool the
pool is a successful pool um but because
um it is a successful pool and and we
the the am the Investments um we're not
we're not only investing in New
Hampshire for sure we have some
Investments not only uh in US treasuries
we have Investments um of um other banks
that operate in in the country so those
are the ones you know large large large
Banks um large corporations so we have
the ability to invest in those in those
compan companies um so no I guess to
answer your question is is not broken
it's a very successful pool it has the
highest rating um that s SMP can um
award um so um hopefully that answers
your question could I answer
that thank you so it no one is
suggesting that there's something wrong
with the
pool however we're I think we're missing
an opportunity
to have some portion of New Hampshire
taxpayer
funds be
reinvested in our communities and become
available for commercial lending for
retail lending and if you recall from
April 17th briyan got's study indicated
that when you looked at property tax
Collections and room and meals
collections primarily also business
taxes on a state level there would be a
secondary positive Revenue impact for
the cities and towns
Beyond just looking at the rate of
return so that's the reason for this
bill
grassy yes this is a question for the
treasurer as well um the city of Ro does
not belong to the pool they're not
investing in the pool they invest their
money in a private investment firm um my
concern is if this bill would pass and
it would in some way create a situation
where the pool would have lower returns
could this force a lot of towns who are
currently invested in the pool maybe to
drop out and go with a private
investment firm instead of the pool or
with the banks uh if they feel they're
getting they getting a better rate which
I have this feeling that some of these
and I spoke to my treasure Treasurer
about it that you know investing in a
private firm um I don't look at as being
as safe as investing in the pool and you
know that's a concern would you could
you see that this would could drive
towns not into the banks but into
private investment
firms that is definitely the risk I mean
again trying to make a change that will
you know we're creating unintended
consequences
um that is the risk the risk is um you
know even though we will try to manage
uh the portfolio manager is going to try
to um meet the requirements of a change
in the law but if for some reason
something goes wrong then you lose the
um the confidence of investors and
investors will take their money out and
once that happens then you no longer
have a successful pool we have a higher
ratio expense ratio to to operate um you
know with less funds so right now what
makes it a successful pool is that
people have confidence that the pool is
has the highest rating um the towns and
cities have been able to invest their
funds the state New Hampshire has a a
position in that in this pool so I'm
very confident that the money is there
safe um because it maintains the highest
rting in order to maintain the highest
rating you need to have a lot of um
controls in place um you know follow the
guidance of the investment adviser plus
you know having a strong investment
policy there are a lot of pieces I mean
the the myself and um and the and the
advisory committee meets on a quarterly
basis to to monitor this performance so
there are a lot of pieces that are are
you need to have in place to make it
work so again an unintended consequence
if we change the law that that is my
concern and this is why uh I just wanted
to mention um the
concerns thank you both oh yes
representa
Lane uh thank you um take my question
did I hear you say that you could
address some of these issues through
policy changes and not and would not
require a statutory
change that that's exactly what I said
uh representative uh I think we could
try to again understanding there is this
desire to try to have a a um um you know
more deposits in the state so the so the
banks operating and the state can do
more lending and all of that I think we
can look at what all the states I do and
there's there were some examples um
shared with us um the state of Missouri
the state of New York they do have some
type of requirement that um in their
investment policy to to to deposit a
portion of the funds that are invested
in the pool and those funds operating in
in those States so I think we could look
at that we could try to achieve you know
a goal that again we will leave more
funds in this the state so there are
some risks of course because um you know
perhaps there's some costs you know
perhaps you know if we if we want to
leave some more funds in the state
perhaps um the yield could be impacted
but we'll consider all of that as part
of what we reviewing and and I think we
could probably find a a a sweet spot and
but but again address it in the
investment policy um rather than the law
um the the cities and towns have a
requirement to have an investment policy
um so themselves can um you know decide
how much money they want to um save in
the pool already so I think we all we
all uh all treasurers um have to abide
by this investment policies in order to
make the decisions that work for again
for the state and cities and towns and
you know in their cases can I you're
welcome to senat Rose thank
you right now the
um investment
policy allows for investment into
financial
institutions in New Hampshire however
there are zero
so yet I think trust would
verify if if our goal is to maintain the
safety which is the top priority of the
pp in statute but also ensure a good
return and all and finally grab those
tax revenue impacts that we know we will
get I think it would
be I think it would be wise to move
forward with at least targets
on what the Investments can be and what
a goal for banks
is but not set an absolute
floor
because we can leave it to the
investment policy and then just not see
a
change represent McGuire has a few
questions thank you Mr chairman thank
you for coming um Madame Treasurer
there's an advisory committee that um
you are a member of and and um sets
policy for the fund um and that advisory
committee has some members of New
Hampshire Bankers on it is are the
meetings of this committee contentious I
mean do you do
you you know is it all against the
bankers or something like that or is
everybody in generally an
agreement on decisions thank you for the
question I I um this bill um has made
some uh interesting um reactions you
know during the meetings but I think
um my experience with with this board
has been you know always everybody gives
along fine it's just I think that
discussion you know again trying to the
discussion related to this bill has has
become a little more um um contentious
uh during our meetings but I think but
that's that's another opportunity I
guess going forward I think you know
having a me the members from the bankers
Association and also members of
participants of the pool I think going
forward could allow us to again what
what Senator rosenal is is is trying to
um accomplish here is to try to find a a
compromise right to try to so so um it
it is correct that this pool has not
been able to
um leave funds in this in the state but
uh but it is possible to put a mandate
and the policy and try to achieve that
um we can certainly look into that I'm
always I'm always um um I've had the
oversight of the pool only for less than
a year so we haven't had the opportunity
to to review all aspects of you know
what the pool should be um review the
investment policy has been around for
some time so this is also opportunity to
review the investment policy um with the
committee members hopefully I answer
your question yes thank you thank you
may I follow sure thank you so um the
key part of this bill that uh it seems
to me is uh on line nine the words
insured or
collateralized so my maybe naive
understanding when I invest in say a CD
or something I get FDIC insurance
but it's only up to
$250,000 and and so I'm careful not to
put more than that in any given bank
right for some strange reason I can have
as arbitrary amount of FDI insurance if
I put some in this bank and some in that
bank some like that but if I put it all
in one bank it goes away you know it's
not there but this is way more than
$250,000 so I assume this what this is
talking about in terms of insurance
is not FDIC Insurance am I right or am I
wrong I think it would be a combination
of of I think what the bill is is is
saying it could be a combination of DIC
insurance and other type of collateral
um so um some banks use some products
that um utilize FDIC insurance and and
this particular product goes and finds
collateral and in other Banks throughout
the state throughout the country uh but
there are other forms of collateral it
could be us treasuries although
obligations um uh layers of credit those
are common and and more secure uh ways
of to collateralize in addition to FDIC
Insurance all right let me one more so
if something is insured or
collateralized is is that kind of the
difference the reason that that causes
lower interest rates is because what
you're investing in now is something
like commercial paper which doesn't have
insurance and this would and therefore
one is a higher interest rate and the
other is lower is that right I think the
interest rates depend on the the banks
all banks have different policies and
they have the ability to set different
rates collateral definitely cost uh
there's a cost um always there's only I
don't know exactly how much I I think
there's one Bank mentioned 12 basis
points for for the cost of collateral
but I think that the I'm not really sure
that's across the board but it does cost
money so I think um the rate is impacted
by their business and also their ability
to collateralize
funds thank you are we ready for a
motion
or are there any more questions for the
state treasurer of Senator
rosenwall seeing
none um we are ready for a motion
represent Maguire so I'd like to move
interim
study and I'd like to talk about that
and it's seconded by representative wer
so I spent some time yesterday with OS
to to ask about you know to talk about
possibly amending this bill because my
original thought was what we heard at
the public hearing was that the people
who are invested in this bill the
various Town Treasures County treasures
and so on they liked it and they don't
want us to to mess with right and so um
so I was I had the idea that well uh but
on the other hand you know in deference
to the Senate which was unanimous on
this bill um why don't we have two pools
right and let the people who invest in
it decide do I want it the one way that
we have it now or do I want it the way
that that this uh this bill would change
it to and then let the various counties
and towns and so on decide how do they
want to invest their money and so we
went I went around with the um with OS
talking about that and it turns out that
effectively what we have now in law is
that right because there's a law which
tells towns here's how you can invest
your money and one choice is p dip and
the other choice is
okay all right but but there's there is
yet another maybe there's another
section and maybe it's certain kinds of
funds certain kinds of town monies can't
be that way I don't know anyways what
what we saw in the law was it's either P
dip or or Banks maybe there's some other
choice that we miss but um but the point
is it seems to me that we already
have um uh a lot of choice right and and
so therefore the amendment I was
considering didn't make sense to me
because because it seems to be that's
what existing law is and so but maybe
there's a germ of an idea here and so
therefore interim study instead of
itl Representative Griffin Follow by
representative grass you I think had a
question um when I first read this bill
it appears to me it was a great idea and
then we heard
testimony and I noticed that most of the
people who sent emails and testified
against it were members of the
pool and most of the people who
testified for it were not members of the
pool so I changed my mind 100% I I would
itl this bill but interim study is
yeah I mean this is one of the things
that when I sit down with my finance
director and and and we talked about
where Rochester Rochester invested their
surplus funds in Bar Harbor trust it's a
formerly a Rochester company so they
have some you know some personal
relationships there I suppose but the
concern that I had and I expressed to
them and I said you know what are you
getting for a rate and I said you could
probably get a rate better rate with the
pool and I said and what happens if one
of the partners abcon with a bunch of
money um you know you've got no
protection and it was like oh yeah okay
and so you know the thing is is that uh
you know not that barab is going tosone
with their money they're a reputable
company but the thing is is that a town
could invest in a company like that
which would be very unsecure and that's
the concern that I have is that you know
you don't you have more choices and I
don't want to really encourage people to
invest in private companies that are out
there Loosey Goosey um accepting
deposits from communities um you know
they may come up with a good proposal
for you and you invest your money and
then all of a sudden the money's gone um
I I think what we have now is a safe
situation and I would hate to see that
change I'm not opposed to itl to take a
look at this but um or inim I mean inm
Stud I'm not opposed to inm study to
take a look at this but you know my town
has said you know we don't think it
should change and but my county has said
they don't think it should change
so representa Sweeny name is chairman I
I do appreciate all all everyone's
position on this only wondering if the
committee would indulge a day delay on
the vote till tomorrow afternoon uh
there may be an agreement that can be
reached uh on some ver version of the
bill if we just had an extra day if that
would be acceptable with I would I would
support that I mean there's so much
interest and concern on both sides in
this bill I think it makes good sense
not to act really hastily on it where
pres McGuire are you okay with
that um it's really are you CU you won't
be here tomorrow
so representative hacken Phillips will
be sitting in for me tomorrow so okay
yeah I'm I don't mind it's it's the
similar to interim study right a delay
one day of interim
study all right so we will uh recess
this um
until let's see
end of the end of the day
tomorrow all right so just it's clear
this will be uh heard again tomorrow at
p.m.
e